The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, so first
I think you should start
thinking about the project.
And what I'm looking
for is a short report,
paper-type report.
I want a limit of
only five pages.
And it could be anything
related to this subject.
So if you happen to be
working on something,
you want to extend and
apply the knowledge
that you learned
in this subject,
you're welcome to do so.
And in fact, I
wrote a paper based
on term paper I was working on
when I was a graduate student.
I thought that that
was a good experience.
In fact, it turns out
to be the first paper
on thermal conductivity
of quantum wells.
I was taking a
linear optics course.
I spent the whole semester.
And at the end, I
went to professor,
I said, I don't
understand what you talk.
And he wanted a term paper.
And I said, how about--
he was talking about
[INAUDIBLE] the Feynman diagram.
So I still don't quite
understand what [? is ?]
the Feynman diagram.
But so I said, how
about I worked on paper
on quantum wells, thermal
conductivity of quantum wells.
He said, fine.
That's fine.
So I wrote the term paper.
And I continued to work
on it, and I eventually
actually published a paper
on the thermal conductivity
of quantum wells.
And looking back at there,
because of the-- let's say
I was doing pretty much
a Boltzmann equation.
So completely forgot
about quantization.
But it turns out the most
of the stuff were correct.
Not everything was correct.
And so what I want
to say is I encourage
you to think about subject
related to your research.
It can expand that.
Or if, say, you
don't have a subject,
you can do a literature review.
And then say you're interested
in a specific topic,
let's say metamaterials,
or plasmonics, or any
of the things that we
mentioned or you read,
you are going to
apply the knowledge.
You can do a literature
review and expand on it.
Maybe you say,
OK, based on that,
maybe this is an
interesting problem
that I can continue working on.
You can work after
this semester.
You're always welcome
to discuss with me.
And if you really don't-- let's
say you don't have a topic,
come talk to me.
I think I can always
figure something.
We can negotiate and see
whether it would be interesting.
OK?
So that's the term paper.
So now you have all turned in
your first midterm and redo it.
Any questions on
those first midterm?
I think I say, when I
was looking at where
were most of the mistakes made,
I think one of this is the
depths of the evanescent wave.
And probably because unless you
go back-- you've written down,
and it may not be easy to
figure out what's the depth.
But the key is you should
be able to write down
the plane wave expressions.
And if you have the
plane wave expression,
and you use your Snell's law,
and you can find the angle
when the angle cosine theta--
or sine theta is larger than 1.
So you use your cosine theta
1 squared root 1 minus sine
theta squared, and they
plug in the plane wave,
you should be able to find
out what's the penetration
depth of the evanescent wave.
And there was another
question about what's
the number of molecules
have a certain speed.
That's a gas molecule.
And so there, I
would guess probably,
you maybe get [INAUDIBLE]
what's the total number of--
you need to start with the
total number of molecules
per unit volume.
And that's the first value you
need to-- given temperature,
given pressure, you could
use the ideal gas law
to find out what's
the local density,
and then use the Maxwell
velocity distribution to see
what's the total number, or
what's the number of molecules
that have a certain velocity.
And then I think it's
a matter of time.
Most of you couldn't finish
the last problem, where
we're looking at the phonon--
the equivalent of
phonon distribution
to the black-body
radiation, where the peak
Wien's displacement is null.
So you find out that in many
cases, a low temperature, yeah,
you do have a peak.
But at high temperature, that
wavelength, peak wavelength,
is too short compared to
times the lattice constant.
So you actually never
reach that peak.
It will be-- you should
continue to try that out.
And for many years,
I haven't done
that myself until this
time, because I have
to make a problem out of it.
This is the optical absorption.
That's the second
longer problem,
what's the optical absorption
for a direct gap semiconductor.
And it's a matter of
joint density of states.
So if I have--
so I have a
semiconductor dispersion,
and I have a photon.
This is the [INAUDIBLE]
electron from the valence band
to conduction band.
And then you need to say, this
is my photon energy, h omega--
mu.
And how is it related to k?
So you need to
first write down--
because you know this
parabola, this parabola,
and the difference
of these two energy
gives you the photon energy.
So once you have photon
energy or frequency versus k,
and you can use the normal
way we do density of states,
because the absorption depends
on how many states you have.
And this is, in fact,
called the joint density
of states between the valence
band and conduction band.
And then it turns out it's the
same as your bulk material.
That's the square root
of E minus the band gap.
So the absorption of the light
for a particular semiconductor,
this is--
this curve of absorption
is a reflection
of the joint density of states.
And of course, you
have the population.
We didn't say, OK, you have to
say how many electrons here,
how many empty states here.
If I do it, I really
just say this is the F,
and here F for the number
of electrons here is empty.
So that's a 1 minus F.
But that's a different F,
because there-- if your
chemical potential is here,
and you say the Fermi-Dirac is,
say, energy minus mu, and here
is the valence band
energy minus mu there.
So basically, if
you force yourself
going through those
problems many times,
you can understand a lot
of the basics that you see.
And I did not do this before.
And this time I said, OK,
I'll give you problems.
I have first to do it myself.
Any questions?
OK.
So for now, let's come back.
And if we think what we
were talking the last time,
we talked about this
wave-to-particle transition.
And from that, I
said, from now on, I'm
going to neglect the phase
of the energy carriers,
the plane wave and--
I'm no longer caring
the phase, I'm
just looking at the
trajectory and treat them
as [INAUDIBLE] so looking
at the trajectory.
And for that, we say--
we discussed briefly
the Louville equation,
which is the N particle
distribution function.
And that is, of course,
the N is a huge number
of particles in my system.
And we say, OK, from
this Louville equation,
there are generally
two approaches.
One is the Boltzmann equation
that [INAUDIBLE] developed.
And the other is the
linear response theory,
which I hope I will have time
by the end to cover some.
If you do molecular
dynamics, you
should really dive into
linear response theory.
That's the analysis.
I commented a lot of
people, in fact, say,
any undergraduate
student coming in
can conceptually understand
F equal ma, do a simulation.
But the key is you have
to really understand
the basis for that.
And so we move on and say,
OK, from f to N And to f of 1,
that's one particle
distribution function.
That's the Boltzmann equation.
And the f N is just
the multiplication
of f1 for N particles.
And because of the one
particle, now this particle
will interact with the rest of
the particles in this system.
So the Boltzmann equation,
which you roughly
can show from Louville
equation, the left-hand side
is df dt the first derivative,
because here is still
a function in phase space.
f is the distribution function,
still function in phase space.
So the first derivative is
gradient with respect to space.
The second gradient is with
respect to the momentum.
And it's actually interesting
to comment, the f,
it looks like a function
of x, y, z, vx, vy, vz.
It looks like it has a
direction. vx, vy, vz,
if a particle is going
in a certain direction,
I have a different f.
But the question is,
it's a vector or scalar?
What do you think?
It's a scalar in high
dimensional space.
And if you just think about
the-- any point in space
and particle going
in specific direction
have specific distribution.
So that looks like it has
directional properties.
But that directional
property is really
the [? wave ?] coordinate, the
higher dimensional coordinate
in space--
phase space coordinate.
OK.
And also, there are different
ways to write this fourth term.
dp dt is the same--
if you look at, think about
the [? Louville's ?] law,
dp dt gives you
the F, the force.
And the force, you can
write F, because p is ma--
mv, so I can put an m out and
f, say, derivative with respect
to v. Well, p is
a function of hk.
So I can use
different variables.
Rather than using
p, I can use v,
I can use K, and a different
way of writing these terms.
And that's most
of the time, say,
when you deal with
the electrons,
you have to keep this term.
That's the important driving
force for the electron motion.
When we deal with
photon or phonon,
we do not need this term or
even, say, the molecules.
There's no direct force on them.
But the computation is really
on this left-hand side--
right-hand side, where
I say now the particle
interacts with the
rest of the particle.
And that's the collision term.
So let's move on and try to
write down this collision term,
because so far it looks
all pretty simple.
On the left-hand
side, you can say it's
the first-order derivative.
And so let's look at the
collision term, df dt.
This is not a derivative.
It's just a symbol
how we can express it.
And normally, I can
start just to consider
the two-particle collision.
And so if I have two particles
interact with each other--
and this initially,
this particle
has an energy and
momentum or wave vector--
hk is the momentum--
and this other
particle has an E1 k1.
And when they get close to
the interaction range, what is
the close to interaction range?
And so if you think
about two gas,
say, atoms, it's
the electrons when
the electrostatic potential
can interact with each other.
So you have electrons,
you have nuclei.
So you have-- that's where
they start to interact.
So if you think about the
gas molecules in this room,
we see the average mean
free path of 100 nanometers.
And the atomic size
is a few angstroms.
So there is actually a very
large space in between them.
Most times, they
do not interact.
They will just travel freely.
And when they're getting
really close to each other,
you get this collision.
But due to the collision, you
have the energy change, maybe.
And you are changing
the direction.
So that's the final state
for this first particle.
And you have the energy change
of second particle and momentum
change of the second particle.
And in a typical
problem, what you want
to say, OK, what's the first--
what's the rate of--
what's the probability?
What's the rate?
And the way to do this
is a proximate method.
So if you have--
originally, if you
solve a method--
for example, if I have a photon
comes in and getting absorbed
by the materials-- getting
absorbed by the material,
so originally, the material
has a certain energy,
and that's, quantum
mechanically,
I have these solutions,
allowable energy levels.
That's what we did in
the second chapter.
So original problem, this
system, before interacting,
has an energy.
And correspondingly, we can
write the Schrodinger equation.
Essentially, we can
write a Hamiltonian,
which is the kinetic energy.
So h bar squared 2m k--
so it's the operator, that's the
first term in the Schrodinger
equation--
and plus u0.
So when we solve the
Schrodinger equation,
we say this one equals mass
i h bar d [? plus i ?] dt.
We solved for the energy states.
So now what I
have-- so this is--
we did the steady state problem.
Now, during photon
comes in, what it does
is to create a perturbation.
You treat it as a
small perturbation
to the original Hamiltonian, H.
So let's say this is your H0.
And the small
perturbation, let's say now
the interaction
Hamiltonian H is H0
plus a small perturbation, which
could be a function r and t.
All right.
This is the interaction term.
This is the original
unperturbed,
where I already have--
supposedly, you already have the
Schrodinger equation solution.
You know the energy level.
You know the wave function.
It's the quantum state
of the original system.
And due to this
perturbation, you
go back to the
Schrodinger equation,
you solve it using
perturbation method.
We're not going to do it.
And with that, you
can find the rate
of perturbing due to
this perturbation,
the system changing from
one state to the other.
And this rate is
the transition rate.
This is from the initial
state to a final state.
And this is a 2 pi h bar.
And we have the integration of
the final state wave function
complex conjugate
the perturbation.
So this is the
unperturbed system,
the wave function--
let's suppose
you start with a certain
initial state wave
function and the final
state wave function.
Let's suppose you already have
solved the original problem.
And now, given
this perturbation,
Hamiltonian, and I have the
initial state wave function,
and I interact--
integrate over the volume
of that interaction.
And this is squared,
and then a delta
function Ei minus Ef, which
says the initial energy,
the energy conservation
delta function
is 0, when the Ei
does not equal Ef.
So only when Ei equals
Ef, this is non-zero.
So essentially, what this
gives us is the energy
conservation of the system.
And if you do this,
if you see, when
you do the wave
function for plane wave,
you have wave vector.
For each quantum state,
And if you do your
integration of this,
you'll also find a corresponding
concentration in wave vector.
That's your momentum
conservation.
So what you have,
essentially you
will get the momentum
energy conservation
from this transition rate.
And so they-- you have, for
example, the initial energy.
So this is the
two-particle interaction.
So this is initially,
E is a function of k.
And the incoming one, E1
k1, equals E prime k prime.
It goes scatter
into another state,
and the E1 prime k1 prime.
So that's the
energy conservation.
This is that delta function--
the initial of the two systems,
two particles, and the final
of the two particles.
And the corresponding
energy conservation
is k plus k1 prime
equals k prime--
that's the final--
plus k1 prime final.
And let's say, just
with-- [? hold ?] on this.
And because hk, hk, that gives
me momentum, later on I'll
make of a modification
to this form.
Here can say this is a
simple momentum conservation.
But later on, we'll
add-- so in crystal, you
add reciprocal lattice g.
And that's a so-called
Umklapp process.
But basically, those transition
rates also give you--
in doing the math,
also you actually
get the energy and the
momentum conservation.
And most of the time,
you can say people do not
like to write those integrals.
That's why the Dirac, if you
read the quantum mechanics
book, they will
write Dirac notation.
And the Dirac notation for
this is your initial state
interacting--
that's like a wave
function here--
interaction with
perturbed Hamiltonian
and goes to a final state.
So that represents
this integral.
And you have this integration.
OK.
And you also write this as
a matrix form, f i squared.
So there are three different
ways to do quantum mechanics.
One is the matrix, do the
Heisenberg; Dirac notation,
Dirac; and the Schrodinger
is the Schrodinger equation.
They are all equivalent, OK?
So this is the famous
Fermi golden rule.
Next time you heard Fermi
golden rule, you'll know this.
And this we have said.
So that gives you the
transition rate from the initial
to final with--
given the interaction
Hamiltonian.
This is by showing the time
dependent Schrodinger equation
using the perturbation method.
OK.
So that's the first step.
We say we're dealing
with the collision.
And now coming back to
the Boltzmann equation,
I'm looking at the one particle.
And this particle can
collide with many particles
in the system.
So I have to count all
the other possibilities.
And so the-- now I can start
writing df dt, this collision
term, df dt, this collision.
First, if this particle is
collide to other states,
then I have a loss, right?
It goes from original E k
state to E prime k prime state.
Then this f, because f is
represented in the one particle
at a specific state, so I
lose a particle in that state.
So my first term is going out.
That's a loss.
So I have a negative sign.
So it's going out.
And of course, that depends on,
say-- the rate really depends--
say first, I have the rate here,
collision rate for two quantum
states, but then I need to say
in each quantum states, how
many particles I have.
So I need to say f, really
the initial t, r, k,
and if it collides with
the other one, t, r--
at the same location--
k1, so how many in
k, how many in k1?
And what's the rate
of going from k, k1,
to k prime k1 prime?
So this is where the Fermi
golden rule tells me those are
how many to start with, OK?
So this is a loss.
And now because I'm
counting one specific,
so I need to really, say, sum
up all other possibilities.
So I need to sum up k1,
I need to sum up k prime,
I need to sum up k1 prime.
That summation is actually--
because each k is a wave
vector, is a vector,
actually each of these k's
is three summations.
So I have really nine
summations. k1 is a vector,
k prime is a vector, and
k1 prime is a vector.
This is a loss.
And then there is the gain.
That's going from the reverse.
Say, how many k prime, k1
prime scatter and scatter back
into the current state of k?
So the gain is from t, r--
so here, this is where
the Boltzmann equation,
where the molecular
chaos assumption we
used before, right?
So it's only interacting
at our point.
So I'm not writing
a different r point.
I mentioned that there
are modification.
People try to consider final
size of the atom or molecule,
like [INAUDIBLE] equation.
In that case, you have to
either two different r points.
That becomes a lot
more complicated.
So here I have k prime.
That's from the initial
state is k prime.
And t, r, same, and k1 prime.
And they will interact and going
from k prime, k1 prime going
to k, k1.
But what I care is really
just this one specific quantum
state in k.
So I need to sum, again,
all those other states.
So this is k1, k
prime, k1 prime.
So this is summation
index, as I said.
So this is out, this is in.
I'm doing the number balance.
And you put in that summation
into the left-hand side,
right-hand side of the
Boltzmann equation,
you gather the full
Boltzmann equation, OK?
Now you can say this
was just a starter.
The real thing is
the computation
is on the right-hand side.
And most times, we do not
write this as a summation.
You can use what
you learned, how
to change your summation
into integration.
k is a sum in the
quantum states.
Now you need to convert that
summation into integration.
As long as all
the assumptions we
made apply here, so if
you convert this sum
issue into integration,
what do you have--
in terms of the number
of integrations?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: Line.
Each of this is a vector.
So you have [? line ?]
nested integrals.
And of course, when you
convert state, you do 2l--
the distance is 2 pi over l.
So you have that distance.
You have all this constant
from converting summation
into integration.
And you have [? line ?]
nested integrals.
And this [? line ?] nested
integrals is d k1, a vector.
So I can write three.
There's d k1 x, d k1 y, d k1 z.
And d k prime and d k1 prime.
So this is from converting
summation to integration.
The second comment is
this W. It turns out
that one could argue that
this W equals this W, that's
a detailed balance.
And in equilibrium, everything,
[? say, ?] is the same--
scatter out equals scatter in.
Otherwise, you
have this one state
either will be
depleted completely,
or it goes to below to infinite.
That's the detailed balance.
So because of that,
you have the equality.
So you write it and write in two
terms you can split-- write it
into-- combine into one term.
So at the end, what I can
write is scattering term df dt,
say, equals--
and I put a negative sign in
the first term in the front.
I have then W and f t,
r, k and f t, r, k1--
so this is the
first term-- minus--
let me write this here--
the second term is, say, f--
minus f t, r, k prime
and f t, r, k1 prime.
Let me just make
another comment.
And here, I'm writing
two fixed particles.
When you do a real problem--
whether, for example when
your electron interacts
with a phonon, at the
end, the electron--
the phonon may be
absorbed, so you
don't have a phonon coming out.
So for each of
the specific case,
you need to carefully
write down this f.
Here I'm just
writing a generic way
of if I have two particle comes
in, collides with each other,
I have two particles goes out.
But say, when you actually
have photon getting absorbed,
photon disappear.
So you need to do each of this
case just using the same idea,
do your detailed expression.
And so you read the different
papers, different problem,
this will be
different expressions.
OK.
So now I'm going to solve this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Never mind.
I was just wondering,
what's the point
of having an integral
representation of this
when we're probably going to
be doing this numerically?
And then because this also
has to have the assumption
that these functions
are slowly varying
for every infinitesimal step--
GANG CHEN: Yeah.
So integral-- that's true.
You can go back to summation.
But then remember, in the
past, before computers
were very powerful,
people always
tried to say whether I
can solve it numerically--
analytically.
But so that's the--
and in fact, I say most of
the time this function doesn't
change that rapidly.
So that's a valid approximation.
It's not as bad as,
say, the line integral.
The reason is that, you see,
when you have collision,
you have these delta functions
So it's those delta function
in energy conservation.
And the delta in
momentum conservation--
this is also delta function--
was significantly constrained.
What are the possible
values you have to consider?
So that's the-- that will allow
you to simplify and make this
still [? trackable. ?] But I
have to say that solving full
Boltzmann equation-- now
I'm not going to write--
combine the left-hand side
to the right-hand side,
left-hand side to
right-hand side--
what you really have
is a differentiable
on the left, integral
equation on the right.
So even though you are solving
one specific state with k,
you have to consider all the
other k's in your system, all
the quantum states
in your system,
to solve these
distribution functions.
And in transport, of course, if
your temperature is changing,
say as a function r, so every
point you consider all the k's.
And you solve-- so the
way that the people,
some people try to solve
for each of these fields--
there are not many--
twice.
It's pretty complicated problem.
And let's say you typically
do an iterative solution,
because this one is
for a specific k,
but this integration
involves all other states.
Your solution has to meet
all those requirements.
OK.
So it's the integral
differential equation.
And the integration
is in k space.
The differentiation
in both, say,
real space r and the p, k space.
But this is very hard.
And this equation, the
Boltzmann equation,
is used by electrical engineers.
It's the foundation you can
derive all the electrical--
the equations the
electrical engineers use.
And it's used-- a lot
of the past literature
is on gas dynamics,
rarefied gas dynamics.
A lot of studies in
Do you know the reason
why there are so
many studies in gas dynamics?
This is due to Apollo Project.
Why?
Because when you try
to send the spaceship
through the atmosphere, when
you go outside the [? IRC, ?]
go to outer atmosphere,
the pressure is very low.
The molecule mean free
path is very long.
So it's in the rarefied
gas flow regime.
So a lot of study in rarefied
gas dynamics in the 1960s
region, time scale.
Now they're studying neutrons.
You go to look at the
neutron transport,
there are a lot of works just
solving neutron Boltzmann
equation.
So you've got the neutron
Boltzmann equation,
you've got the gas
you've got the electron
Boltzmann equation,
you can do electron and
the phonon and photon--
I teach another course,
radiation transfer.
At the end, we solve this
equation for the Photons
that's when you
completely ignore
the phase of the
particles, of those waves.
So this is a--
that's why really, there
are not many equations.
If you start from here, you
can derive all the equations
that every field,
or most of fields,
use in the transport regime.
But it's a molecular
chaos assumption.
So this is only valid when
the particles are diluted.
That's why so far I've been
doing electron, phonon,
photon molecules more
on a parallel path.
I can't deal-- you can't use
Boltzmann equation for liquid.
That's not right.
OK.
Now, moving on, this is
a hard equation to solve.
So there is a creative
way to make it simple.
And that creative way, now we
have Boltzmann equation right,
so we do relaxation
time approximation.
I say I can't deal with
these nasty integrals.
So what I'm going to write is--
you'll be happy.
Forget about the
line integral, OK?
This is the relaxation time.
OK.
And now you will feel that
we can probably do something.
And this relaxation
time approximation--
again, there are different
field has a different name.
You put in this relaxation
time on the right-hand side
of Boltzmann equation, you go
to rarefied gas dynamic, or gas
dynamic, but it will not be
called Boltzmann equation.
It will be called
the Krook equation.
So in the gas dynamic, that
will be Krook equation.
And in other
fields, people don't
call it the Krook equation.
So I remember once I
was giving a seminar.
And a question was, oh, you're
not solving Boltzmann equation,
you're solving Krook equation.
At least I know who is Krook--
what is the Krook equation.
OK.
So the-- [? why ?] it's
the relaxation time.
And if you put in
the right-hand side--
and let's forget the
spatial dependence--
then what I have
is df dt equals--
so if your system is uniformly
disturbed from equilibrium--
f0 is the equilibrium
distribution--
then you can stay
here, if you solve
this system will return
f to equilibrium,
f0 equals exponential
t over tau.
So you can see this
exponentially relaxed back
to equilibrium.
That's why tau is called
the relaxation time.
And typically, we call
this Boltzmann equation
under relaxation
time approximation.
Sometimes, people also call the
linearized Boltzmann equation,
but there are some
confusion there, I think.
So now let's go to discuss
what's the relaxation time?
What's the scattering?
And let's look at the
different relaxation times,
different process, scattering.
In general, when I think
about the scattering
and the relaxation
process, of course
we can say-- we mentioned
before photon absorption.
So if I have--
before, we say, OK, this is
my-- the problem we worked on.
This is my semiconductor
with a bandgap, wave vector.
So you know it's 3D.
And if I have a photon comes
in, excite from here to here,
and the photon
momentum is very small,
so when I do my
energy conservation,
this is the electron
initial energy,
and this is the final energy.
And initial energy, you also
have the photon energy, right?
It's a two particle.
So initially, I have electron
at the E [INAUDIBLE] energy.
And initially, my
photon has energy h nu.
And then finally, the
electron has energy Ef.
So I have my energy
conservation is Ef minus Ei.
This is the initial
electron energy that
equals h bar omega or h nu.
That's the photon energy.
And the momentum
is kf equals ki,
so the final momentum
of the electron
plus the photon, h
bar k, of the photon.
And of course, the
photon wavelength
is a micron, typically.
If 1 micron is 1.1 above
the 1 electronvolt,
the band gap is typically
electronvolt, few electronvolts
or 0.1 electronvolt.
So you can say that
the wavelength, lambda,
is of the order of 1 micron.
And here, the zone
boundary is pi
over A. A is the
lattice constant.
The lattice constant
is angstrom.
So you can say that, say, lambda
really doesn't shift this.
The photon momentum that
does not shift the k much.
It's just very little change.
So it's essentially a vertical
transition in this case.
And that's the homework
problem you did--
no, the midterm
problem you did, right?
And of course, you
can extend this.
If you do an indirect gap
semiconductor like silicon,
and say, silicon I
have a valence band
here, conduction band
is not the minimum
and somewhere here,
this is a silicon
indirect gap in general.
And now when the energy of the
photon is right at the gap,
you can say there is
not enough momentum.
The photon cannot leave the
electron from here to here
along, because the
momentum k is not enough.
So what it does is
it will interact--
you will actually
have three particles--
an electron interacting
with the photon
and interacting with the phonon;
phonon, very small energy,
milli-eV to tens of milli-eV.
And the wave vector,
on the other hand,
the momentum is large.
So you can write your--
in that case, you'll say,
OK, the indirect gap,
if this transition happened,
it will involve both electron,
phonon, and photon.
Ef equals Ei plus
h omega, photon.
And it could be plus or
minus h bar omega, phonon.
So what the plus minus
means, if it's a plus,
it absorbs a phonon.
Phonon gets in.
If it's a minus,
a phonon emitted.
So that's your
energy conservation.
Now you have three
particles involved.
And kf equals ki plus h bar k
photon, which you can neglect.
And in the case of
phonon, this energy is--
still, you should carry
it in your analysis,
but this one is pretty small--
and plus minus h bar k phonon.
So now if you can
do this problem,
you should be able to
do this problem using
the joint density--
try to write down this
joint density state--
joint density of states and
say, if you have an indirect gap
semiconductor, how
the absorption would
change near the band gap.
So those are the things
now you can apply.
And of course, what I say--
what the general behavior
is for direct gap,
this is your energy gap, Eg.
And you have a very sharp
rise in the absorption.
But the indirect gap, it could
be lower phonon absorption
or higher.
But the rate will
be much smaller.
And that's the-- we
mentioned before, this
is a problem of silicon when you
try to use it as a solar cell,
because this absorption
is not very strong, which
[? typically ?] means you can
have to use very thick material
to absorb the photons
to capture it.
And that is the cost
of the materials.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you actually have
that free body interaction?
GANG CHEN: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or is it [INAUDIBLE]
first and the photon
has to provide the critical
gap, and then [INAUDIBLE]
that energy?
GANG CHEN: Oh, that's a--
this is a very good question.
It's a rate problem.
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
GANG CHEN: It's a rate, right?
So whether it happened
if you have absorbed--
and I think because you probably
can have some mismatch due
to the uncertainty principle.
But I do not say--
so you-- sometimes, you can say
you raise that virtual state.
And then you need the
other thing to come in.
But see, that's very short.
So almost instantaneously,
you have to have that.
So that's another reason
why this one is smaller.
The scattering matrix
will be weaker.
And that's in this
region is smaller.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you were here to
provide a lattice vibration
for indirect band
gap semiconductor,
could you theoretically convert
it from indirect to direct?
GANG CHEN: How-- oh.
Could you-- what's
the question again?
AUDIENCE: Basically,
providing the phonon--
GANG CHEN: Right, right.
Well, you don't have--
see, this is-- you
can't shift this one.
There are some ideas
how to shift it.
The idea to shift it is
using quantum size effect.
That's the first problem I give
in the quiz, the short problem.
Now, when you use a very small--
so what happens is
this one will rise,
the next-- the first level
will become here rather
than at the bottom.
And if it's small
enough, this one
rises here and be
lower than that.
That depends on
the effective mass.
If this is a sharp, this
is a very, very-- see,
the flat means a
large effective mass.
That means you need a much
smaller diameter to raise it.
So you have to look at the
effective mass of each band.
And of course, when
you make small,
this will also going down.
And some of you see this is--
the first problem
is that you have
to consider what's going on
for the conduction band, what
goes down.
When the multiply-- when the
effective mass is the same,
you multiply it
by a factor of 2.
That's how you
enlarge the band gap.
OK?
So this is a photon--
well, maybe I can
make one more comment
and relate to
[INAUDIBLE] question.
Some people will say, OK, let
me develop an intermediate band
gap solar cell.
What does that mean?
This is a band gap.
And some of the
infrared photons is not
absorbed, because there's
not enough energy.
So the idea is, OK, let
me develop a energy level
in the gap by putting in
other atoms or quantum
dots in the region.
And then the infrared
photon now can go from here
to here, the first photon.
And then the second photon
goes from here to here.
It's a nice idea.
That's hard to do.
Why?
This is a matter of
time, residual time.
You need the electron
to here, and it
has a tendency to get lost.
The competition,
this is all rigged.
If it relaxes back or it
interacts with a phonon
and becomes heat, then you lost.
So you have-- if you can
stay there long enough,
wait for the next photon
to come to lift it,
you can go to calculate
roughly, back of envelope,
if you have certain
photon density coming in,
how long it takes
for the next photon
to come in with
that certain energy.
And the other way is,
say, there are also
the so-called
two-photon absorption.
What happens is two photons
come in at the same time,
at same place, and you
get that transition.
But you can see
in that case, what
they need is a very high flux.
Because they need to come at
the same time and same location,
so you need a lot of it.
So nonlinear optics is
two-photon absorption.
They require very
high intensity.
You use lasers to do that.
And in fact, many times you need
a very high intensity lasers
to get nonlinear regime.
So it's all related to the
rate, the time, when you
think about what's possible.
There's a concept there.
This is rate concept
is very important.
How fast is the process?
And you can dream, for example,
I have some electron comes in--
photon comes in.
I can lift the electron--
sometimes I can have absorption
from here to here, free carrier
absorption.
And say, OK-- or I have a
high energy photons comes
in, because the solar spectrum
have a lot of photons like
that--
you raise the electron here.
Isn't it good if you take this
electronic energy out rather
than go back to here?
Most solar cells, this
electron will go here,
then you take it out.
From here to here is about
a picosecond time scale.
So you look at the
how long it takes--
how 1 picosecond, how much
electron will travel, you say,
that's very hard.
So this rate process, those
are the very important,
getting this order right.
So this is-- we say, OK, energy
transport, energy conversion.
What is it?
This is an energy
conversion, wouldn't you say?
the energy is going
from photon to electron.
And there are, of course,
many competing processes
if you do a device.
And the other processes are
electron-phonon once you
get the electron, and
the phonon-phonon.
So let's look at phonon-phonon.
So far, when we talk about
phonon, we did dispersion,
we did a spring, mass-spring.
That's the idea of
harmonic oscillator.
And they do not interact if I
just have harmonic oscillator.
Photon is a harmonic oscillator.
Photons do not interact, OK?
So it's the unharmonic term
that will cause the interaction.
And for phonon, in fact,
it's hard to get a photon
talk to each other,
interact with each other.
Like I said, nonlinear optics,
you need a very large flux
to get them together, right?
But with a phonon, which is--
in [INAUDIBLE], the lattice--
this is the potential
we draw before.
And harmonic approximation is
approximately at this point
in my parabola.
So here is the potential,
here is the distance.
And if I say, if you write
down the higher-order term--
this is the minimum, and the
first order is [? gone ?]
1/2 k x minus x0 squared.
So that's the harmonic term.
And then you have unharmonic--
the next term is unharmonic.
So you expand your potential
using Taylor expansion.
It's d d x square, say,
x0, and x minus x0 cubic.
There is order, first
order [? gone, ?]
second order, third order.
You can write fourth order.
Now you do your spring constant.
Your force is df du minus dx.
Of course you get your spring
term, harmonic spring term.
That's what we use when
do phonon dispersion.
But if you go to your next
term, your higher-order term,
you'll get the x
minus x0 squared.
That's the third-order term.
So that gives you not a spring,
linear spring, a nonlinear
spring.
Now, if you have two
phonons, each one
has one specific frequency,
you do their product
of the two phonons.
Omega 1-- sine omega 1 times--
omega 1 t times sine omega 2 t,
what do you get?
You get plus minus.
That's a nonlinear term.
So you start to have
the two sine waves
interact with each other if
you have those nonlinear terms.
Otherwise, it's just a
linear superposition.
They will never
change the frequency.
So this is the source of
phonon-phonon interaction.
And the unharmonic fourth
term gives you the part--
because of this, you can see
if I have omega 1 comes in
and omega 2 comes in,
you can go omega 3.
That's a sum.
So what it means is
two phonons become one.
Or you can have one
phonon split into two.
So you have the omega
1, omega 2, omega 3.
And then in the process,
you have energy and momentum
conservation.
This is h omega 1 plus h
omega 2 equals h omega 3.
That's for-- this one is
the absorption process.
And in phonon language, we
don't call that absorption.
We say that annihilation.
OK.
See, maybe I should
not pronounce that H?
Annihilation.
Annihilation, you agree?
And here is a creation.
One becomes two.
So this is a creation process.
So say, for this, you can
write a corresponding energy
conservation.
Now, momentum conservation
is interesting.
And normally, I would
write h bar k1 plus h bar
k2 equals h bar k3.
This is normal.
And in fact, this is
called normal process.
OK.
But normal process,
that scattering actually
does not create a
resistance for heat flow.
Why is that?
Let's think about the
vector format we just did.
So what I have, if I draw that,
that's a momentum conservation.
So this is a h bar k1, h bar k2.
And this is when they
combined, they form h bar k3.
That's normal process.
Now, originally I have
h bar k1 is carrying out
heat h bar omega 1.
And h bar k2 is carrying
heat h bar omega 2.
Now, if it's a normal
process, this final one
is carrying energy of
omega 1 plus omega 2.
That's the same as the original.
And also, the direction
is the sum of the two.
So essentially, the
[? lattice ?] effect
is if I have heat flow,
this creates a negative flow
in this direction.
This is final one
is still carrying
that same amount of heat
flow in the same direction.
So this normal process actually
does not create a resistance.
And what happens is if I
think about the dispersion,
so phonon dispersion
transfers, not Schrodinger.
And so you have
to consider phonon
from each different branch,
and whether they can satisfy
the energy conservation.
This is k and the
specific direction omega.
And sometimes, when this
one goes beyond the h k1,
let's say, and here is k2,
k1, k2 go beyond the Brillouin
zone, get a much larger k.
And in that case,
the crystal symmetry,
the reciprocal lattice
here, this point G--
it could be another
direction G. I'm just
drawing on the
same branch, but it
could be a completely different
branch, two phonons interact.
And if you do the wave
analysis, so what's better
allowable process is h bar
k1 plus h bar k2 equals h bar
k3 plus h bar G. This G is
the reciprocal lattice vector.
in chapter 4, we talked
about the Fourier transform
of crystal lattice point
into Fourier space.
This Fourier space has
a corresponding lattice
constant G. And
that G is that G.
And this process, by
adding another vector G,
you could go completely
different random directions
that's not the original
high flow direction.
So with this process, it still
has the energy conservation,
but the direction change due
to the crystal momentum here,
this creates the resistance.
And this is called
the Umklapp process.
It's a German word.
I think-- I'm not sure, but this
explanation comes from Peierls.
Peierls was a--
Peierls, I think
he's a British guy.
So I don't know why
this is Umklapp.
But I remember when
I was a student,
I actually heard a talk,
similar given by Peierls--
he was in his 90s--
at Berkeley.
And he told the
interesting story.
And he said, you know Landau.
And I'm not sure the
[INAUDIBLE] Landau book.
If you read through that book,
you understand everything.
Landau, he said Landau
was telling people--
he'd say he considers himself
as a third-rate scientist.
And so people ask him,
who is the first rate?
He say Einstein
is the first rate.
Who is a second rate?
Heisenberg or Dirac
is the second rate.
So he's third rate.
OK.
Now I'm trying to rate myself.
So this Umklapp process creates
resistance for the heat flow.
And there are different-- so
people have used those kind
of--
used the Fermi golden rule
and derived some expressions.
But those-- for example,
for Umklapp process,
the relaxation time is--
one expression that's used is
the [? bi ?] temperature and kT
kd T-- that's in the exponent--
T cubic omega squared.
But I want to caution you.
This was actually
done in the '50s,
and all the approximation
made in those derivation.
And while, for example,
[? common ?] approximation is
the [? bi ?] model, which
is a linear approximation
to the dispersion.
You know it's not
going to be valid
when you go to high frequency,
the high wave vectors.
And so there are different--
for normal processes,
their expression, Umklapp
process, their approximation.
And also, there are
unknown constants.
And those constants are
the scattering matrix.
And if you don't
know, so typically
people use this as
a fitting parameter.
And that's phonon-phonon
scattering.
Now, there are-- for
other scattering phonon
are the impurities.
You have, say, harmonic
oscillator, you have silicon.
And you dope it.
You dope boron, you
dope phosphorous.
Those have a different match.
So when the wave comes
in, say, a different mass,
they'll be scattered.
And this scattering is
typically impurity scattering.
And remember, last time I said
phonon-phonon scattering is--
you can treat it
a complete phase
randomizing, because pop
up here, pop up there,
you can't fix the position.
But we have impurity scattering,
this impurity atoms are fixed.
It's just you can't-- you
normally don't know where they
are.
And the impurity scattering
form is typically
written as a fourth power--
inverse.
Here can see I
all write inverse.
So in fact, this is
a result not derived.
It's a result from light.
And if you look at the
sky, it's a blue sky.
And that's because
the light is scattered
by the density fluctuation of
the gas or small particles.
And so when you have small
atoms or small particles,
you can say the higher
frequency, this tau, is the--
this is tau, right?
Tau itself is smaller.
They left at the
relaxation time.
That means they
scatter more often.
So that's why the sky is blue.
That's the Rayleigh scattering.
This is the Rayleigh scattering.
Acoustic waves,
and optical waves,
they all have those
characteristics.
But it's not completely
sure in what regime
this is applicable for
acoustic, atomic waves.
This is still some debate there.
And finally, this is a boundary.
There is also a boundary.
If there's no scattering
[? hits ?] boundary,
there is boundary scattering.
And that's the one
that will actually
solve Boltzmann
equation using this
as a boundary condition
of Boltzmann equation.
We can treat it more rigorously.
But typically in
the past, people
will do is when you have
different relaxation time,
you patch them
together, particularly
if they are or randomly
distributed in the volume.
And you do this total tau equals
the different process inverse.
So it's a more resistive one,
the more frequently scattered
one that will be dominant.
Because this is all inverse.
And this is the
Matthiessen Rule.
OK.
So that's you put all these
different processes together.
One final comment.
So here is the
phonon-phonon scattering.
And then you have the
electron-phonon scattering.
We have electron has a
certain energy, interacts
with a phonon, gets into a
different energy, E, E prime.
And also in the process, you
have the energy and momentum
conservation.
And this scattering,
of course, you
deal with the
electron transport.
That's very important.
Electrical engineer
always trying
to improve their mobility,
try to make a faster device.
You want to reduce
the phonon scattering.
And so the one thing
I want to comment here
is, of course, the
energy change process.
If there's an energy
change, it's inelastic.
The energy is not conserved.
The particle energy changes
during this scattering.
And the impunity scattering,
like the Rayleigh scattering,
typically, these are
the elastic scattering.
Elastic scattering,
frequency doesn't change.
And in fact,
rigorously speaking,
for all inelastic
scattering processes
where the energy challenges, the
relaxation time approximation
is not valid.
We do it all the time,
but this actually
[? rigorously ?] not valid.
So you will go-- once
we go to chapter 8,
we'll have one more step.
Let's suppose you split this,
say, into two terms rather than
just the relaxation time.
So that's when we deal with
electron-phonon and line
equilibrium between
electron and phonon.
OK.
So I think I will
stop on this topic.
And now I think we
come to the stage
I would say, you
should pick up the,
as I said at the
beginning, any journal.
And you should not say you--
or say that you should not
be afraid of reading.
I'm sure that you can't
understand everything,
but what I'm hoping
is there are always
things that help
you to get some idea
of those different many papers.
So let's take a quick look.
So all the-- I
think I have covered
most of the basic concepts.
And the rest is
if you read paper,
of course, the concept
that need time to digest.
And well, I was quickly look
at the, let's say, Nano Letter.
Now, you can look at all--
I will say, you should look
at all the nano journals.
This is two.
OK.
So silicon nanowire.
This is the more device related.
I thought we can look
at the current issue.
Where is the current issue?
More materials.
How to make materials,
that's relatively easy.
OK.
For example, if you go to next
one, paper by David Smith.
He was a guy first who did the
negative refraction experiment.
And the surface plasmons.
If you look at the
title, "locally tuned
surface plasmon resonance."
You've heard of surface plasmon.
You can read and see what
it means, what's it doing.
And if I look at this one--
I didn't open it, but
you can go to check
whether I guessed it right.
So if I look at this electric
breakdown of state lattice
region [INAUDIBLE] graphene
junction, probably they're, OK,
break down--
of course, it can
create the gaps.
But there also could
be tunneling phenomena
if you have very small narrow
gaps, electron tunneling.
I don't know whether the paper
will deal with those issues.
All right.
And where I stopped--
Water, you have
to wait when we do
the linear-- more Einstein
treatment, linear response
theory.
And when we look at
battery, one concept
that I'll go into another
[INAUDIBLE] battery,
but you have to
understand what is
the electrochemical potential.
And conducting
graphene, nanocubes--
so I guess my message to you
is, now you go to these journals
and try to read
through the title,
and guess what it's doing.
And you pull out a few
papers, and you try
to read through the content.
A lot of you are
concerned-- does this
help you pass the [? core? ?]
The [? core ?] is asking
to read the papers.
And [? you see ?] they
will ask you questions.
So that's-- I think it
should help but no guarantee.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.